hey märz vor einem Jahr war
Bundestagswahl wenn die Wähler an dem
Abend an dem Tag gewusst hätten was an
Gasrechnungen Stromrechnung auf sie
zukommt wäre Regierung im Amt heute
also vermutlich hätten wir ein anderes
Wahlergebnis bekommen wenn die Welle die
Wählerinnen und Wähler in Deutschland
auch nur einen Hauch einer Ahnung gehabt
hätten wie wir regiert werden dann hätte
es dieses Wahlergebnis nicht gegeben er
davon auszugehen dass mit ihnen die
Gasrechnung in Deutschland heute
niedriger werden wir hätten die
Angebotsseite klargestellt wir hätten
auf diesen angebotsschock mit einer
Ausweitung des Angebotes reagiert und
wir hätten über den Sommer neben der
Verstromung von Biomasse neben den
Kohlekraftwerken aus Steinkohle und
Braunkohle auch die Kernkraftwerke
sichergestellt dass sie laufen und zwar
nicht nur im streckbetrieb sondern auch
mit neuen Brennstäben man muss doch in
einer solchen Situation jede Quelle
nutzen die man hat um Energie zu
erzeugen wir verstromen immer noch Gas
in Deutschland wenig aber für Strom noch
Gas das hätten wir sicherlich so nicht
akzeptiert diejenigen die arbeiten hart
arbeiten Steuern zahlen von denen können
sich ganz viele die Heizung zu Hause
sich leisten während das Flüchtlingen
und hartz-empfängern seid ihr ganz
vielen Jahren bezahlt wird die warme
Wohnung ist das ungerecht das ist
ungerecht und das wird auch von den
Menschen zu Recht als ungerecht
empfunden und zu allem setzt die
Bundesregierung noch die Krone auf indem
sie jetzt dieses neue Bürgergeld
einführt das wird uns in den nächsten
drei Jahren mindestens 20 Milliarden
Euro kosten wir hätten dieses Bürgergeld
in dieser Form nicht eingeführt wir
hätten das Prinzip fordern und fördern
beibehalten es macht keinen Sinn
Menschen die schon in der
Arbeitslosigkeit sind und jetzt noch mal
Bürgergeld hinten drauf bekommen sechs
Monate alle Freiheiten zu geben sich
nicht um ihren Job kümmern zu müssen
also hier werden schwere Fehler gemacht
die wir auch in den nächsten Jahren noch
in ihren Auswirkungen und zwar auch dann
sehen wenn die Energiekrise hoffentlich
längst vorbei ist rechnen Sie in diesem
Herbst Winter mit Blackouts in
Deutschland ist das dann in Scholz
Blackout
in dieser Situation
müsste doch eigentlich der Bundeskanzler
in der Lage sein diese Regierung
zusammenzuhalten und zu führen wo ist
eigentlich der Bundeskanzler hat der
eigentlich zu diesen Themen auch eine
Meinung oder überlässt er erst im
Finanzminister und dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister naja aber man
kann auch mit Corona und vor Corona sich
mal zur Sache äußern man kann mal ein
Kabinett zusammenhalten wir erleben
jetzt wochenlange Streitereien dieser
Koalition und ein Bundeskanzler der sich
zu diesen Themen nicht äußert der keine
Regierungserklärung abgibt der im
Parlament nicht auftaucht also dies ist
eine Krise der Regierung und dies wird
eine Krise des Bundeskanzlers Blackout
ist ja nicht irgendwas sondern es ist
schlicht dunkel dann für eine Zeit in
Deutschland das wäre vorher vor einem
Jahr noch völlig undenkbar gewesen kann
eine Regierung sowas durchhalten
Blackout in Deutschland also lassen wir
uns mal nur auf wenige Minuten
Stromausfall oder vielleicht einige
Stunden Stromausfall die hiesige
Bürgermeisterin hält das ja für
verträglich lassen Sie mal drei Stunden
in den in Berlin den stromausfallen oder
in den großen Kühlhäusern den
stromausfallen wir werden schon nach
einer Stunde Stromausfall merken welchen
volkswirtschaftlichen Schaden das
anrichtet wir können uns das in diesem
Land nicht leisten und wir müssten es
auch nicht akzeptieren wenn wir eine
bessere Regierung also das stünde in der
Verantwortung der Regierung das steht
allein in der Verantwortung dieser
Regierung die wertvollste Zeit vertan
hat mit Streitereien ohne die Probleme
wirklich zu lösen und überhaupt in
Krisen muss man dann mit einer
restriktiveren Flüchtlingspolitik
arbeiten wir sehen mit großer Besorgnis
dass die Entscheidung der
Bundesregierung
vom System der asylbewerberleistung auf
das System der Arbeitslosengeld 2
Zahlungen überzugehen im Frühjahr zu
erheblichen Verwerfungen auch bei den
Flüchtlingen aus der Ukraine führt wir
erleben mittlerweile einen
sozialtourismus dieser Flüchtlinge
nach Deutschland zurück in die Ukraine
mehr als 1,1 Millionen Flüchtlinge
insgesamt bisher den Stand heute eine
größere Zahl sich dieses System zu Nutze
machen da haben wir ein Problem das wird
größer wir haben im Frühjahr darauf
hingewiesen dass dieses Problem
entstehen konnte die Bundesregierung hat
sich taub gestellt und muss man also in
diesem besonderen Krisenzeiten in der
Flüchtlingspolitik noch strenger sein
bei der Aufnahme ich finde wir sind in
der ganzen Einwanderungspolitik in
Deutschland seit längerer Zeit nicht
wirklich konsistent wir brauchen auf der
einen Seite Fachkräfte nach Deutschland
aber wir müssen auf der anderen Seite
dafür sorgen dass die Zahl derer die
nach Deutschland kommen und hier auf
Zeit oder auf Dauer bleiben
striktbegrenzt werden und dass du die
Bundesregierung nicht im Gegenteil sie
ruft nun mittlerweile dazu auf dass alle
nach Deutschland kommen die hierher
gerne kommen würden das ist mit
Sicherheit der falsche Weg und das löst
im übrigen soziale Spannungen aus die
wir uns in diesem Lande wirklich
ersparen sollten wenn diese Regierung
crasht
in ihrem eigentlichen Zeit vor den vier
Jahren sind sie Standby könnten sie
heute übernehmen die Opposition von
heute ist immer die Regierung von morgen
aber wir arbeiten nicht auf den Crash
dieser Regierung wenn es nötig wäre
wären wir selbstverständlich in der Lage
zu übernehmen das ist überhaupt keine
Frage aber noch einmal wir müssen in der
gegenwärtigen Situation ein gemeinsames
Interesse daran haben dass dieses Land
gut regiert wird ich habe allerdings
Zweifel wenn eine Regierung und ein
Bundeskanzler noch nicht einmal in der
Lage ist seine eigene Regierung
zusammenzuhalten dann wird da wenig Zeit
darauf verwenden können noch andere mit
ins Boot zu nehmen
[Musik]